y
hola hola christine buenas tardes bueno
hoy christine de canacar mi méxico y
gracias por venir y feliz regreso a
clases
estamos aquí para tener una sesión de
preguntas y respuestas y también vamos a
compartir un poco más del campeonato
directo de matemáticas y ciencias y
también
cómo usar khan academy con tus alumnos
este año escolar
pues aquí tenemos para ti garcía gracias
por venir también hola a todos
bienvenidos a este programa de
capacitación mi nombre es para ti garcía
yo trabajo para detective y también
trabajo muy de la mano con cristina
y bueno antes que nada felicitarlos por
este inicio a clases esta semana
regresamos todos a la escuela y bueno
para eso estamos aquí porque cada
academy tiene muchos programas muchos
proyectos para hacernos de este regreso
a clases un proceso pues más fácil más
divertido más eficiente entonces tenemos
muchas cosas que compartir con ustedes
hay muchos proyectos
a muchas actividades que estamos seguros
que van a ser de gran utilidad para
ustedes y que de verdad van a
permitirles que el año escolar no que el
principio del año escolar sea mucho más
agradable para todos no siempre cuesta
trabajo regresar a clases pero realmente
khan academy tiene grandes planes para
hacer no los todavía más divertido bueno
estamos aquí para apoyarlos con el
objetivo de maximizar los resultados
académicos de todos sus alumnos a través
del año escolar
recuerden que khan academy es una
organización sin fines de lucro cuyo
objetivo es ofrecer una educación de
primer nivel para cualquier persona en
cualquier lugar en cualquier momento eso
es lo lo maravilloso de esta plataforma
el enlace para esta presentación es el
que tienen en la pantalla si ustedes
tienen su dispositivo a la mano les pido
que entren que pueda abran una ventana y
en una ventana pongan este enlace y van
a poder tener acceso a esta presentación
y podrán también guardarla bajarla a su
disco duro etcétera en caso de que no
tengan su dispositivo a la mano les
sugiero que tomen una foto de lo de esta
imagen de esta diapositiva para que más
adelante puedan acceder a la
presentación y bajarla
si podemos anotarla en el chat será de
gran ayuda a christina
y ya está la vida ok vamos a esperar
unos minutitos para que ingresen todos
los que puedan
ok tenemos ahora una nueva página de
soporte técnico en español está
realmente maravillosa esta página porque
da respuesta a todas las preguntas que
podemos tener respecto a la plataforma
lo único que tienen que hacer es hacer
clic en este enlace y entran aquí a la
página de ayuda les sugiero les sugiero
que la añaden a sus favoritos y bueno
dentro de esta plataforma de esta página
tenemos por ejemplo solución a los
problemas más comunes que pueden
presentarse en khan academy no
tenemos también los a los problemas con
dispositivos módulos perdón móviles
tenemos también una sección de preguntas
frecuentes ok no como abrir una cuenta
cómo crear un usuario
como administrar sus cuentas existentes
qué pasa si pierden su contraseña
etcétera y tenemos otra parte de
preguntas a la comunidad donde podemos
obtener puestos trucos etcétera de cómo
hacer un mejor uso de la plataforma de
khan academy entonces si les sugiero que
lo guarden en sus de sus favoritos y van
a tener realmente acceso a esta a esta
página que va a ser de gran utilidad
voy a regresar a la presentación y bueno
cuál es la agenda del día de hoy y la
idea de hoy es primero tener una visión
general de la plataforma para aquellos
que ya la conocen vamos a hacer un
rápido repaso de cómo crear nuestras
clases cómo eliminar también nuestras
clases viejas etcétera para aquellos que
nunca la han utilizado bueno esta es una
excelente oportunidad para crear su
cuenta para comenzar a abrir sus
primeras clases el objetivo es que
ahorita que estamos comenzando clases no
que estamos en nuestra primera semana
del regreso a clases pues utilizamos
esta información para comenzar a
utilizar la plataforma para crear
nuestras clases y para ya echar a andar
esta plataforma y este la implementamos
dentro del salón de clases porque les
aseguro que va a ser de una gran
utilidad
yo como maestra de matemáticas y de
ciencias de secundaria les puedo decir
con certeza que esta plataforma de
verdad sin exagerar cambio la vida de
muchos de mis estudiantes
otro tema que veremos es que lo que
tengo que hacer como docente para
empezar ya a utilizar khan academy y por
último dejaremos un tiempo para una
sesión de preguntas y de respuestas
entonces vamos a ver primero el primer
tema de nuestra agenda es una visión
general de la plataforma entonces lo
primero que yo les voy a pedir es que
para entrar a la plataforma en español
abren una ventana y teclea ese punto
khan academy punto org esta es la
plataforma en español
entonces entren a este a esta dirección
y automáticamente van a entrar a la a la
plataforma yo me voy a salir en este
momento y voy a entrar a la plataforma
para poder verlo de sacar entonces me
voy a salir de mi cuenta voy a finalizar
mi sesión y vamos a empezar desde cero
esto va esta información madrid-a para
aquellos maestros que nunca han
utilizado canacar en si nunca la han
utilizado rápidamente les voy a decir
aquí cómo pueden crear su cuenta y la
verdad es que son tres pasos muy
sencillos para seguir no entonces lo
primero van a ir a ese punto canal khan
academy punto org
se abre esta ventana y lo primero que
ustedes van a hacer es seleccionar
maestros inicien aquí vamos a hacer clic
en esta parte y aquí les da tres
opciones para abrir su cuenta puede ser
con google puede ser con facebook puede
ser con tu correo electrónico les
sugiero yo que lo hagan a través de su
correo electrónico porque es el día de
mañana cierran su cuenta de facebook
etcétera van a perder todas van a por su
cuenta y todas sus clases entonces vamos
a elegir regístrate con tu correo
electrónico y aquí basta con que
completan ustedes esta información van a
poner su correo electrónico van a poner
su nombre su apellido y van a crear una
contraseña con al menos ocho caracteres
ya sea mayúsculas números símbolos
etcétera recuerden de anotar en algún
lugar que ustedes sepan para que no se
les olvide y una vez que estén listos
con esta información este botón se va a
encender se va a poner azul y ahí le van
a hacer clic en regístrate en el momento
en que le pone en regístrate los va a
meter automáticamente a su cuenta
aquellos que ya tienen una cuenta de
canicas nedim y de khan academy vamos a
hacer click en iniciar sesión e íbamos a
poner el correo con el cual nos
registramos
y vamos a poner la contraseña
que creamos para nuestra cuenta y vamos
a dar click en iniciar sesión
entonces tanto aquellos que acaban de
abrir su cuenta como los que acaban de
entrar nuevamente a su cuenta ustedes
van a entrar automáticamente aquí a esta
página aquellos que apenas crearon su
cuenta bueno esta parte la van a tener
vacía porque no han creado ninguna
cuenta quiero hacer notar antes de
seguir aquí revisando la plataforma que
ya está aquí el botón para inscribirse
al campeonato para aquellos que no han
escuchado que es campeonato en unos
minutos más adelante le presta en la
presentación les voy a explicar de qué
se trata
desde aquí usted desde el momento en que
entran a su cuenta ya desde aquí pueden
inscribirse ok yo siempre bueno quiero
recordarles a todos los que tienen ya su
cuenta ya los que apenas les están
abriendo informarles que con este botón
de khan academy este es en el logo
digamos yo siempre que hago clic en el
logo de khan academy automáticamente la
plataforma me va a llevar a mi página
principal como selecciono yo cualquiera
sea mi página principal en la plataforma
aquí al lado tenemos tiene cada uno su
nombre vamos a hacer clic en el nombre y
nos vamos a ir a configuración
al hacer clic en configuración nos vamos
a ir hacia abajo y yo aquí puedo cambiar
mi nombre etcétera pero me voy a trabajo
y acá abajo me dice roles recuerden que
en can academy yo puedo ser maestro y
tener el rol de tutor de maestro pero
también puedo ser alumno yo al igual
puedo estar tomando a lo mejor una clase
de cálculo con un colega no o en otro
lugar etcétera esto yo puedo jugar los
dos roles entonces yo les va a pedir
aquí que se aseguren de tener activadas
aquí las dos palomitas que estén como
estudiante y que estén como maestro y
tutor y aquí abajo dice página del
inicio van a hacer clic en la flecha y
yo les sugiero que elijan la página de
control de tutor para que sea su página
de inicio esto quiere decir que siempre
que hagan clic en el logo
automáticamente los va a llevar a su
página como maestros entonces van a
poner aquí guardar cambios
una vez que hagan esto vamos a hacer
clic nuevamente en el logo y fíjense
como automáticamente me va a llevar a mi
página principal que yo elegí que fuera
mi página como docente ahora otra
pregunta importante no cómo puedo
cambiar de mi rol de maestro a mi rol de
alumno
recuerden que aquí desde mi nombre si yo
hago clic aquí en página de inicio del
aprendizaje yo voy a entrar a mi página
como aprendiz a mi página como
estudiante yo aquí puedo ver las tareas
que tengo pendientes quiénes son mis
tutores etcétera así para yo regresar a
mi cuenta como maestra hago clic
nuevamente en mi nombre y ahora digo
panel de control del tutor del docente
entonces automáticamente me lleva a la
página principal de docente no como yo
como maestro entonces éste viene siendo
la página principal de mi cuenta no yo
desde aquí puedo ver qué
tengo que estudiantes tengo generada los
recursos etcétera
ahora como creo en mi primera clase
vamos a ver en esta parte lo primero es
cómo crear una clase y la siguiente
parte que vamos a ver es cómo eliminar
una clase estamos comenzando el año
escolar y es súper importante ahora sí
que eliminar todas nuestras clases
muertas todas aquellas clases del año
pasado que ya no vamos a utilizar que ya
no vamos a enseñar ahorita es el momento
de eliminarlas para comenzar frescos
comenzar no únicamente con aquellas
clases que van a estar activas durante
este año escolar nos vamos a comenzar
con cómo crear una clase lo primero que
vamos a hacer es aquí del lado derecho e
inferior vemos aquí el botón que dice
agregar una clase vamos a hacerle clic
en agregar una clase se abre esta
ventana y aquí yo lo que tengo que hacer
es seguir tres muy sencillos pasos
lo primero que seleccionar es el nombre
de la clase en este caso yo voy a decir
de modo
capacitación
khan academy s no me lo voy a poner
porque la demo para esta capacitación
siempre utilice nombres que sean muy
específicos porque a lo mejor si yo
estoy dando 3º de secundaria sean
específicos si es período a período b o
grupo 1 grupo 2 grupo 3 c lo que sea
para que los podamos identificar más
fácilmente ahora si yo estoy trabajando
también con google classroom basta con
que yo haga clic aquí no y me va a
conectar con mi cuenta me incluso le va
a preguntar cómo que si tengo yo varias
cuentas con google claro me dice que
cuenta quieres ya que automáticamente me
va a conectar con mi cuenta de google
classroom y me dice ok qué clase quieres
que yo importe se tardó un poquito pero
ahí automáticamente me aparecen las dos
clases que yo tengo en google cloud me
dice qué clase quieres importar basta
que yo seleccione una clase para que
automáticamente todos los alumnos que
están en esa clase se importen a mi
clase
si yo no estoy trabajando con google
classroom hago ingresa el nombre de tu
clase automáticamente le voy a dar clic
en siguiente y paso al lugar al paso
número 2 que es agregar el curso yo aquí
voy a seleccionar qué curso estoy
impartiendo a esta clase nosotros vamos
a poner que es segundo de secundaria
recuerden que en cana academy yo puede
seleccionar más de un curso porque puede
ser que yo esté en escolar de pre
algebra pero también fundamentos de
álgebra si entonces yo puede seleccionar
más de un curso sin ningún problema y
también puedo cambiar los haya iniciado
el año escolar yo siempre tengo la
opción de cambiar mis cursos y modificar
esta información
no voy a poner pre álgebra vamos a dejar
pre álgebra y segundo de secundaria que
son los cursos que yo quiero dar a esta
clase en este año escolar también pueden
seleccionar ciencias como biología
química
física ingeniería eléctrica y le voy a
dar clic en siguiente el paso número 3
sería ya agregar a mis estudiantes y
aquí tengo varias opciones para hacerlo
la acción que la forma y la opción que
yo más recomiendo es a través de un
código que se genera para cada clase
cuando yo creo en la clase
automáticamente la plataforma me genera
un código que va a ser específico y
único para esa clase entonces cuando yo
tengo a todos mis alumnos en clase
habita en el regreso a clases los
primeros días que los tengamos a todos
juntos yo les sugiero que les anoten en
el pizarrón esta dirección
khan academy punto por diagonal join lo
van a anotar en letras grandes en el
pizarrón y van a notar también este
código en el pizarrón entonces los
alumnos van a dirigirse a khan academy
punto por diagonal join van a entrar
y basta con que aquí en la parte que
dice únete a una clase van a colocar a
copiar el código que ustedes pusieron en
el pizarrón y van a hacer clic en un été
a la clase automáticamente en cuestión
de segundos
ellos quedan ingresados a la clase que
creamos entonces para mí es la medida y
la forma más rápida de hacer que
nuestros alumnos se unan a nuestra clase
también pueden imprimir las
instrucciones estas se están trabajando
ahorita en español
pero de cualquier manera manera pueden
imprimirlas pp escribir aquí el código
de la clase para que los alumnos en caso
de que se salga de la clase pierden su
información etcétera pueden pegar esto
en su cuaderno y siempre saber a dónde
recurrir para poder ingresar nuevamente
a la clase
ok otra manera de invitar a nuestros
alumnos es como les decía importando la
desde google club no seleccionó yo la
clase nuevamente que yo quiero importar
y
me sincroniza con google si yo no tengo
y no estoy trabajando con una con google
classroom puede ser también por correo
electrónico yo aquí voy a escribir el
correo electrónico de mi alumno de mis
alumnos
siempre separados por una coma y un
espacio y invito a mis estudiantes a ojo
aquí porque aquí bueno para poder hacer
esto necesito tener el correo de todos
mis alumnos y también otra observación
que quiero hacer es que yo las veces que
utilizado este método si me ha pasado
que semanas después sigo percibiendo
persiguiendo literal a mis alumnos para
que acepten la invitación lo que la cual
van a recibir a través de su correo
entonces si ellos no revisan seguido su
correo de verdad que puede pasar un mes
y no sé y no se han unido no y luego
están con que mis me puedes enviar
correo otra vez no lo encuentro lo perdí
no lo veo lo borré entonces mi
sugerencia es que siempre opten por
hacerlo a través del código es más
rápido y más efectivo
una vez que ustedes ya invitan a sus
estudiantes automáticamente su clase
queda crear entonces fíjense en los tres
sencillos pasos que hay que seguir
colocar un nombre seleccionar el curso
invitar a los estudiantes y aquí ya te
dice tu clase está creada ya los
siguientes empezar a ccoo a explorar el
contenido de mi curso entonces voy a
hacer clic aquí en explorar explorar el
contenido y automáticamente me abre ya
mi clase si entonces este es mi clase ya
creada cualquier clase que ustedes crean
o que vayan a crear va a tener este menú
aquí yo tengo contenido tareas avance
actividad lista y configuración ok si yo
le hago clic aquí aquí también puedo ver
todas las clases que yo he creado en can
academy y aquí yo voy a ver el contenido
sea para que ellos seleccione discursos
ahí tengo pre álgebra y segundo de
secundaria voy a comenzar con crear será
suponiendo digamos que
estoy en la primera semana o las
primeras semanas del regreso a clases
entonces estoy comenzando con material
pues sencillo voy a revisar propiedades
aritméticas voy a repasar factores
múltiples y múltiplos antes de comenzar
de lleno con los temas ya de pre álgebra
entonces como asignó yo recursos y
material a mis alumnos pues si yo estoy
viendo propiedades aritméticas voy a
hacer clic en el tema y de aquí se me
abren varios subtemas o varios conceptos
que yo debo aprender dentro de este tema
de propiedades aritméticas si yo lo hago
clic por ejemplo en redondear números
naturales yo aquí puedo contar con
vídeos puedo contar con ejercicios es
importante que recuerden que en kant
academy no nada más podemos asignar a
vídeos en khan academy hoy día podemos
seleccionar artículos por ejemplo aquí
tenemos tres artículos para asignar no
en donde si le hacemos clic podemos
verlo incluso como se presenta este
artículo
los alumnos
ay perdón no entonces aquí se presenta
como cómo ve el alumno este artículo
cuál es la vista del alumno puedo
seleccionar también vídeos no puede ser
lo que quiero ver cuál es el contenido
del vídeo lo puedo escuchar y ver antes
de asignarlo
hay varias formas los vídeos siempre son
sencillos concisos concretos fáciles de
entender la verdad es que los alumnos si
los ven porque no son vídeos largos ni
son vídeos complicados no entonces una
vez que yo veo el vídeo
y veo el artículo y puedo incluso
checarlo algunos ejercicios para saber
qué tipo de ejercicios estoy asignando
no entonces puede ser bueno quiero ver
la vista del alumno como el alumno va a
percibir estos ejercicios y una vez que
yo estoy contenta con esta información
yo lo que puedo hacer es únicamente
tienes que escribir un número en
notación extendida voy a asignar este
vídeo ya que lo vi ya que estoy de
acuerdo con el contenido es justo lo que
bien clase va de acuerdo al nivel a lo
que quiero que repasen y yo hago clic en
este cuadrito automáticamente se prende
este botón que me dice estás asignando
un recurso
voy a ver le voy a asignar también este
ejercicio que ya revise
y voy a asignar por acá un artículo que
yo quiero que mis alumnos lean no repaso
del valor posicional entonces ya lo vi y
lo seleccionó automáticamente se fijan
acá que me dice estás asignando tres
recursos voy a hacer clic una vez que
estoy lista para asignarlos y se abre
esta ventana y aquí a bueno tengo esta
parte que esto es nuevo en esta sección
y la verdad no sé es de gran utilidad
porque aquí podemos seleccionar que cada
uno de nuestros alumnos trabaje con un
conjunto aleatorio de preguntas qué
quiere decir esto que todos nuestros
alumnos van a recibir un grupo de 7
preguntas pero diferentes todas
diferentes o sea quiere decir que los
alumnos no van a recibir las mismas
preguntas y si yo selecciono acá todos
los estudiantes recibirán el mismo
conjunto de preguntas quiero decir que
voy a uniformar las preguntas todos van
a recibir las mismas preguntas no
entonces voy a seleccionar yo esta
opción desde aquí yo puedo seleccionar
las
a quienes yo a las cuales yo quiero
asignar esta estos recursos de estas
tareas si yo estoy dando tres grupos de
tercero de secundaria a abc pues desde
aquí los voy a seleccionar no tengo que
irme y abrir cada clase para asignarlo
me estoy ahorrando tiempo y esfuerzo y
desde aquí se lo asignó directamente a
mis tres clases oa todas mis clases y
también acá estudiantes no aquí también
me permite seleccionar a los estudiantes
a quienes yo quiero enviar esta tarea y
aquí nos hace no nos da la posibilidad
de diferenciar de una manera muy fácil
sencilla y rápida puede que esto sea un
repaso y realmente no todos mis alumnos
necesitan ese repaso entonces yo puedo
seleccionar únicamente aquellos alumnos
o aquella alumna o alumno que necesita
este esta práctica este repaso de esta
manera maestros estamos
personalizando el aprendizaje podemos
realmente adaptarnos a las necesidades
de cada uno de nuestros alumnos de una
manera fácil no de una manera que para
nosotros representa un ahorro de tiempo
porque sabemos no y más está ahorita
tanto comenzando el año escolar como
dentro del año escolar que a veces nos
es imposible porque tenemos 150 alumnos
y atender las necesidades de todos
resulta una tarea de locura porque no
solamente enseñamos sino tenemos un
montón de actividades administrativas
con lo que debemos cumplir y pues
definitivamente esta opción nos permite
como les digo a atender las necesidades
específicas de nuestros alumnos a través
de un clic en cuestión de segundos no
aquí voy a poner la fecha límite vamos a
suponer que sea para el lunes ok y voy a
poner la hora de mi clase sin clases
altas no de la mañana la signo de las
nueve de la mañana y hago clic en
asignar
automáticamente si yo me voy aquí a
tareas esta parte también es nueva yo
puedo ver las tareas por alumnos y aquí
me va a aparecer toda mi lista de
alumnos y me van a aparecer las tareas
que yo les he asignado avisos a mis
alumnos a medida que los alumnos
empiezan a contestar aquí en estos
recuadros nuestros cuadritos aparecerá
la calificación que sacaron en caso de
que fue fueran ejercicios si yo hago
clic aquí en por tarea me va a mostrar
las tareas que yo asignado a esta clase
cuando las asigne cuando es la fecha y
la hora de entrega y quienes las han
completado en el momento en que comienza
a alguien a completarlas aquí se activó
un botón para ver el report entonces de
esta manera puedo asignar tareas ahora
pasa también que a veces tenemos algo de
tiempo y podemos planificar nuestras
clases a futuro entonces si yo estoy
planeando vamos a regresar acá que más o
menos
en tres semanas voy a estar viendo orden
de operaciones entonces hago clic en
orden de operaciones aquí yo tengo un
vídeo el cual nuevamente puedo revisar
antes de asignar
ok todos lo puedo asignar
puedo también
asignar un ejercicio no también verlo
revisar cómo lo percibe el alumno
etcétera sí me gusta lo asignó y puedo
haber aquí por ejemplo un cuestionario
qué quiere decir un cuestionario
cuando yo asignó un cuestionario ya ya
ahorita en khan academy pueda asignar
cuestionarios que equivalen como
evaluaciones cortas y también puedo
asignar exámenes de unidad entonces cuál
es la diferencia de este cuestionario
con no con respecto a los ejercicios en
este cuestionario me va a llevar a
asignar al alumno ejercicios de estos
tres diferentes temas que se supone el
alumno ya cubrió orden de ape las
operaciones propiedades a rimas
aritméticas perdón y propiedad
distributiva entonces voy a ver no como
lo ve el estudiante
y esta es la manera en que el estudiante
va a percibir este cuestionario entonces
él va a recibir cinco preguntas pero no
de un tema nada más sino de diferentes
conceptos no él ya debe saber a estas
alturas de las propiedades de orden de
operaciones y factorización mediante la
propiedad distributiva entonces ellos
inician el cuestionario al contestarlo
no van a subir de nivel no iban a ganar
hasta 350 puntos del dominio en khan
academy los alumnos van subiendo de
nivel hasta que dominan en la habilidad
o el concepto entonces si yo estoy de
acuerdo y me gusta esta evaluación yo la
voy a asignar ok pero no la voy a
asignar de inmediato porque yo esto
planeo darlo en dos o tres semanas no a
futuro entonces yo voy a poner aquí
asignar pero bueno me aseguro de que
note
y enviarlo a las clases a las que quiero
enviárselo a los estudiantes voy a
seleccionar a todos
nuevamente pongo la fecha de entrega
pero como yo planeo verlo en unas tres
semanas le voy a poner vamos a suponer
que sea para el 10 de septiembre y a las
9 que es mi clase pero en lugar de hacer
clic en asignar voy a hacer clic en
guardar para asignar más tarde donde veo
estas tareas si yo me voy nuevamente a
tareas aquí tengo cuáles desea por
alumno aquí tengo por tarea aquí están
las tareas las tres tareas activas que
tienen que entregar el lunes pero si yo
hago clic en guardadas aquí van a
aparecer las tres tareas que yo estoy
planeando para el futuro no para la
segunda o primera semana de septiembre
una vez que yo estoy lista para asignar
las ya ha llegado el momento
basta con que yo haga clic en asignar y
automáticamente se asignan las tareas
y ya las encuentro en la sección de
tareas activas aquí ya están todas mis
tareas
esta es la manera más rápida y más
sencilla de poder asignar contenido y
poder asignar tareas o guardar tareas
para el futuro y aquí en tareas en el en
la opción de tareas ustedes podrán
revisar por tarea la calificación que
gana el alumno que se saca el alumno
aquí podrán ver en el caso del juicio
del del examen cuál es la calificación
del alumno y nos da una idea muy clara
de dónde está el alumno de dónde está
colocado el alumno en cada uno de estos
conceptos o de esta evaluación que yo
estoy asignando ahora vamos a pasar a
cómo puedo eliminar una clase me voy a
ir nuevamente
recuerden que se haga clic en el logo me
va a llevar
a la página principal de mi cuenta con
un maestro entonces aquí aparecen todas
mis clases como eliminó en la clase lo
primero que tengo que hacer es
seleccionar la clase que yo quiero
eliminar en este caso me voy a ir a demo
capacitación khan academy varios cursos
pues voy a hacer clic aquí en la en la
debemos de capacitación
y se abre mi clase
una vez que abre mi clase nuevamente
vemos el mismo a menudo no y me voy a ir
en este caso a configuración al hacer
clic en configuración me sale
inmediatamente en la parte superior
derecha no esta opción de eliminar esta
clase
basta con que yo haga clic aquí y
automáticamente me pregunta la
plataforma está segura que quieres o
seguro que quieres eliminar esta clase
le doy ok y la clase queda eliminar ya
es cuestión de segundos para eliminar
una clase y recuerden que con esto yo
estoy eliminando una clase mi cuenta
sigue intacta yo sigo teniendo mi cuenta
con otras clases ahí pero solo eliminó
una clase dentro de mi cuenta
voy a regresar la presentación
para ti tenemos algunas preguntas
adelante por favor no cómo puedo borrar
asignaciones
ok cuando yo me voy me voy a acá
voy a entrar esto
nos vamos a tareas
por tareas
ay
de alguna clase donde tenga alguna tarea
activa
vamos a ver si nuestro
si no vamos a asignar algunas
rápidamente
ok
voy a asignar un ejercicio ok y voy a
asignar un vídeo
los asignó a todos mis alumnos para
vamos a ponerle fecha
a suponer que es fecha para el 24 y lo
asignó automáticamente yo me voy a
tareas
ok si yo selecciono aquí la tarea y le
hago clic en acciones aquí me permite
editar o copiar no o bien eliminar
entonces yo puedo editar mi tarea puedo
también osea si yo selecciono por
eliminarlas o editarla lo puedo hacer yo
desde acá en el botón de acciones y de
ahí puedes cambiar también tus la fecha
de entrega etcétera no entonces yo ahí
digo bueno lo elimina sola cambias y
auto o la copia si quieres crear una
nueva y desde ahí lo puedes hacer
alguna otra pregunta
ok vamos a continuar que tenemos que
hacer como docentes para empezar a
utilizar khan academy bueno como les
contaba en un principio khan academy
está bueno ha planeado muchísimos
programas muchísimas actividades para
este inicio a clases para hacerlo desde
estas semanas pues un proceso mucho más
eficiente efectivo y fácil para nosotros
como docentes a la vez que también esto
lo podemos hacer más divertido más
motivante para nuestros alumnos
la primera noticia no grande de khan
academy es este programa de capacitación
que khan academy ha creado para todos
los docentes este programa de
capacitación consta de tres módulos el
primer módulo ya tuvo lugar fue el 1º de
agosto pero si no pudieron participar si
no entraron al webinar etcétera no hay
ningún problema nosotros vamos a
compartir con ustedes el enlace de de
este primer módulo para que lo puedan
ver y puedan acceder a él etcétera
puedan incluso hacer las tareas para
recibir su primer reconocimiento de este
módulo tenemos el módulo 2 que también
ya tuvo lugar hace una semana más o
menos en este también vamos a compartir
con ustedes el enlace para que lo puedan
ver aquellos que no tuvieron la
oportunidad de entrar y puedan también
cumplir con las tareas con el objetivo
de recibir el reconocimiento
correspondiente este módulo
por último el módulo 3 va a tener lugar
en octubre con en este módulo hablaremos
de planes para motivar a los alumnos
cómo crear ceremonias para reconocer los
logros y esfuerzos de nuestros alumnos
dentro del plantel o de la escuela cómo
podemos preparar a los alumnos para para
un examen y también hablaremos sobre el
reconocimiento a los maestros que están
utilizando khan academy dentro de su
salón de clases
en otro programa que está haciendo
ahorita otra otro gran pues realmente
gran actividad que planeo khan academy
para este inicio a clases es campeonato
campeonato es un programa que can acabé
a khan academy creó con el objetivo de
enganchar a los alumnos motivarlos al
inicio de clases realmente cómo empezar
el año con una actividad conjunta con
una actividad que motive a los alumnos
que los haga sentirse que forman parte
de algo no trabajar por un objetivo
común celebrar un logro en común
etcétera no y yo creo que también es una
oportunidad maravillosa para poder crear
vínculos con nuestros alumnos yo creo
que un proyecto así una actividad así
nos vamos a no nos va a permitir
comenzar el año escolar con el pie
derecho
tenemos aquí shalkan que es el fundador
de khan academy que les tiene un mensaje
y les quiere contar así que de su propia
voz
es campeonato
profesores de méxico los invito ahora
cargan con los excedentes por tanto
también a dos cargas
i
hola soy leonor de canasta de hoy en
mexico para este regreso a clases
khan academy lanzará un reto a nivel
nacional para impulsar el aprendizaje de
los estudiantes por primera vez en
méxico los profesores de matemáticas y
ciencias podrán participar en el
campeonato de canacar además se trata de
un programa de 10 semanas en el cual los
profesores podrán aprovechar el
contenido de la plataforma e impulsar
así el aprendizaje de sus estudiantes
con un reto muy divertido al inscribirse
los profesores podrán agregar a sus
alumnos asignarles tareas y ejercicios
personalizados y revisar su progreso
como parte exclusiva del campeonato
tendremos una serie de actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento que hemos
diseñado con un grupo de investigación
de la universidad de stanford estas
actividades fueron pensadas para ayudar
a los estudiantes a desarrollar
habilidades y estrategias para tener
mentes más fuertes y superar retos los
alumnos ganarán premios y medallas
virtuales para celebrar
y su dedicación les compartimos un
ejemplo de la emoción que este programa
ha generado en brasil y en eeuu
el campeonato correrá del 10 de
septiembre al 16 de noviembre las
inscripciones se abren el 3 de agosto el
programa 100% gratuito y online visite
www.ubm.com peón hartos.org e inscríbete
ser parte de este reto único para este
regreso a clases
[Música]
pues bueno es un mensaje muy inspirador
de el fundador de khan academy y bueno
les vamos a platicar un poquito más de
qué se trata este programa y campeonato
decana académico como lo mencionan en el
vídeo es un programa gratuito para todas
las escuelas todos los niveles desde
primaria hasta bachillerato va a tener
una duración de 10 semanas y bueno las
inscripciones ya están abiertas como
vieron ustedes ya la plataforma ya
pueden inscribirse ya está el botón ahí
para inscribirse algo que quiero
decirles es que en el momento en que se
inscriban todas las clases que ustedes
han creado dentro de khan academy van a
quedar inscritas van a estar ya
participando en campeonato es por eso
que es muy muy importante que eliminen
todas las clases que ya están muertas
todas aquellas clases que ya no usan que
ya no están usando es importante
eliminarlas porque si no van a quedar
dentro del reto no dentro del programa
de campeonato
entonces en este en este programa además
de los ejercicios y de los recursos que
nosotros vamos a estar asignando a
nuestros alumnos semana tras semana
durante las diez semanas que dure este
programa además de eso vamos a estar
asignando a nuestros alumnos actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento que son
actividades que han sido diseñadas en la
universidad de stanford que tienen como
objetivo hacer crear mentes más fuertes
hasta con nuestros alumnos realmente
puedan tener mentes dirigidas al éxito
no que sean mentes más fuertes y más
resistentes al fracaso no sabemos no que
muchos de nuestros alumnos realmente no
tienen fobia a nuestras materias a las
matemáticas hacia las ciencias porque no
las entienden porque no cometen errores
porque por equis razón hoy al final van
creando una mentalidad de fracaso de
desmotivación de frustración etc
y eso obviamente les impide avanzar en
la materia todavía los bloquea aún más
entonces con esta serie de actividades
la idea es desarrollar en los jóvenes en
los niños y jóvenes estrategias de
aprendizaje que conozcan cómo funciona
su cerebro que conozcan cuáles son las
estrategias que funcionan para ellos
pero sobre todo que creen en lo que
desarrollen una mente orientada al éxito
que los fracasos que tengan no los
utilicen más que no como con una
catapulta para el éxito como algo que
realmente los puede impulsar a continuar
aprendiendo a continuar practicando
hasta alcanzar el éxito
las inscripciones como les comenté ya
están abiertas desde el 13 de agosto el
programa comienza el 10 de septiembre y
termina el 16 de noviembre cualquier
alumno de la república mexicana pues
está invitado a participar en este
programa
este programa se adapta como la
plataforma está abierta en todo lugar en
todo momento a toda hora se adapta la
verdad a las necesidades de cualquier
colegio
como pueden participar los tres como
docentes pues lo primero que debemos
hacer es una vez creadas nuestras clases
voy a asignar tres recursos por semana a
todos los estudiantes de mi clase y
quiero aquí reforzar la palabra todos
los estudiantes porque porque aquí la
idea de khan academy es motivar a que el
100% de nuestros alumnos participen
sabemos como docentes ya ya lo sabemos
que tenemos alumnos que siempre están
participando que son súper responsables
que no hacen todo lo que tienen que
hacer pero también tenemos a otros que
les cuesta un poco más que hay que estar
empujando que no participan que no hacen
la tarea que les cuesta no entonces el
que ellos sepan que necesitan de su
participación para que la clase como
conjunto pueda lograr el 100% del
puntaje necesario en cada uno de los
siete niveles niveles que tiene el
programa pues eso nos los motiva o los
obliga un poquito a participar
ustedes van a asignar tres recursos por
semana a todos sus alumnos esto viene
representando más o menos entre unos 30
minutos de trabajo dentro de la
plataforma lo cual la verdad les digo es
casi nada no porque el alumno una vez
que empieza a practicar en khan academy
de verdad les encanta se engancha se
motivan y ellos continúan practicando no
entonces 30 minutos viene siendo hasta
por semana viene siendo poco pero ese es
el objetivo mínimo no tres recursos
asignados por semana a todos sus alumnos
a su vez también como docentes tienen
ustedes que asignar las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento estas
actividades no son de matemáticas y
ciencias son actividades como les
expliqué en unos minutos hace unos
minutos creadas y desarrolladas
especialmente para desarrollar la mente
a nuestros alumnos y promover mentes más
fuertes ustedes a lo largo de la de este
programa van a tener acceso a un tablero
de progreso
únicamente se va a abrir durante este
programa para que cada maestro pueda ver
junto con sus clases cuál va siendo su
progreso y si van alcanzando el 100% de
los puntos necesarios en cada uno de los
diferentes niveles de campeonato
entonces ustedes va a tener acceso a ese
tablero que es el que vieron en el vídeo
y la verdad es muy motivante para los
alumnos alumnos poder ir viendo su
progreso en este tablero cómo pueden
participar sus alumnos completando los
ejercicios que les envía su maestro noé
y a medida que los completan todos van
ganando puntos y una vez que se el 100%
de los alumnos completan los tres
recursos enviados entonces
automáticamente recibirán el 100% de los
productos no en la clase podrá ir viendo
su progreso a través del tablero que
está abierto para esta programación para
está para
para este programa y también los alumnos
van a ir recibiendo premios digitales
que están creados especialmente para
este programa a medida que va a medida
que vayan logrando sus objetivos y sus
metas establecidas no aquellos maestros
que inscriban más de tres clases en
campeonato van a recibir un
reconocimiento especial y también las
escuelas que alcancen más metas van a
recibir un paquete sorpresa por parte de
khan academy
a preguntas cristina
tenemos algunas preguntas del campeonato
por ejemplo un alumno puede estar en el
campeonato en dos materias diferentes
por ejemplo en matemáticas y ciencias
sí sí puede exacto si hay dos clases el
alumno no puede participar en las dos
clases sí exacto sí se puede
hay más preguntas
cada persona que está participando en el
programa de capacitación si recibiste un
correo esta mañana significa que tenemos
tu registro pero
también van a recibir una otra
confirmación esta semana
exacto bueno si ustedes ya no se han
registrado en este programa de
capacitación les vamos a pedir que
llenen este formulario aquí les dejamos
el enlace lo único que tiene que hacer
es copiar ese enlace y entrar a un
formulario completar los datos
cuando les pedimos su correo electrónico
por favor utilicen el correo electrónico
que utilizaron para abrir su cuenta en
khan academy y completan el formulario
una vez que lo complete en envíelo y
también en este tenemos este documento
con información del programa
constantemente estamos añadiendo
información nueva a este documento les
pido que abran el documento o no
utilizando esta liga en alguna ventana y
también lo guarden en sus favoritos para
que siempre que tengan preguntas o
tengan dudas etcétera puedan recurrir a
este documento donde estamos dando
constantemente información actualizada
de este programa de capacitación que va
a tener una duración como de seis meses
nosotros les pedimos a aquellos que no
pudieron hacer el módulo 1 y el módulo 2
que los complete en complete en bueno
vean el vídeo del módulo 1 y completan
la tarea para que puedan ustedes recibir
su primer reconocimiento antes del
primero de septiembre y si no vieron el
módulo 2 que también entran al webinar
al
y ve y completa en la tarea de este
módulo antes del primero de octubre para
que reciban el reconocimiento de este
módulo entonces al registrarse al
programa de capacitación si no lo han
hecho
recibirán información sobre estos
módulos los enlaces que tienen que ver
las tareas que tienen que completar
etcétera
preguntas comentarios
pues bueno si no hay preguntas ni
comentarios no nos queda más que darles
las gracias a todos y recordarles que
bueno la plataforma en español es ese
punto khan academy punto org y que
también contamos con este enlace
en ese punto cero punto khan academy
punto org para que nuestros alumnos
puedan trabajar en la plataforma desde
su celular sin tener que utilizar sus
datos esto es cortesía de la fundación
carlos slim que trabaja muy de la mano
con nosotros y abrió este enlace para
que nuestros alumnos trabajen desde su
celular sin la preocupación de utilizar
sus datos
entonces compartan lo con ellos para que
lo puedan usar y también les dejamos
aquí un correo o la arroba khan academy
punto org al cual pueden dirigir todas
sus preguntas comentarios sugerencias
dudas etcétera
y pues por mi parte es todo muchas
gracias y bueno les deseo para toda la
suerte de todo el éxito para este inicio
de clases y para todo el año escolar
2018 2019
christina quieres agregar algo gracias
para ti y gracias a todos parte por
venir y estamos en contacto van a
recibir más información y también más
apoyo en los próximos meses y también
semanas y estamos aquí
para cualquier cosa gracias gracias nos
vemos hasta luego
hasta luego saludos
chao